let's jump into this first story and uh
this is this is it's kind of a crazy
story i suppose it's either really
really good
unless i guess you're a democrat then
you're probably really angry about if
you're a black lives matter protester
the florida senate has passed the
controversial anti-riot bill
pushed in the wake of black lives matter
protests governor ron desantis
championed the legislation
and is expected to sign it as early as
next week one of the things it does
that democrats are really mad about is
that if you are in your car
and a group of protesters are in the
street and you're trying to escape them
you are immune from civil liability if
you drive through them
so it's you know you want to make sure
you get all that context in there but
they're freaking out because they're
trying to make it seem like
they're granting immunity to people
literally slamming the gas and like
crashing into people that's not the case
but there are a bunch of other
provisions that make certain things a
felony
now i'll say this because i'll need your
help on this one will
i tried looking up what the bill does
specifically like a breakdown
unfortunately if you go to right-wing
sites they tell you very specific things
like this becomes a felony
certain left-wing sites say very biased
things and
reading through it it's like i don't
know it's not that many pages but it's
very
poorly written so can you give us the
gist of what this anti-riot law does
sure well i actually found like their
summary and i went to the florida
legislature and and
got an idea of what they're doing um i
think the biggest thing
it does i mean it's it's really first
off there's a lot of enhanced penalties
so if you're you know
committing one of these crimes like
inciting a riot participating in riot
uh it's gonna there's like a mandatory
minimum for assaulting a police officer
now of six months for example
um it also means that if you're
participating in riot and you get
arrested you can't
get bailed out before you appear in
court so it's like the sort of
in and out i'd like i think that's a
great one um
it allows it has a it has this defunding
anti-defunding the police provision
which essentially makes the state
before city wants to defund its police
it needs permission from from the state
government
uh it looks like it this is an
interesting one and i think this is the
one that
has to do with the whole uh the defense
about like if you run someone over it
says it creates an affirmative defense
in a civil action
arising from a riot if the plaintiff's
injury or damage was sustained as a
result of participating in a riot so
that
that's sort of interesting that sort of
shuts off any sort of lawsuits by
rioters like if you're in a riot and
you get assaulted or something so it's
actually beyond so so the democrats are
the ones framing it as though you could
run a cart your car through them
right but in actually it's much broader
than that like well it's civil liability
too right like say you say
i think that's a good example right
you're participating in a riot um and i
don't actually know the extent of this
affirmative defense i'd actually need to
read it like
you know how far that goes but the basic
concept if somebody is escaping you
don't have the right to sue them
because you were participating in a riot
and they were trying to get out of it
and they why do we need a law for that
if you're committing a felony
and i'm trying to escape why am i liable
for this i mean apparently
you know i think it's good to just make
it really clear actually
you know because people one of the
things i i have a very strong view about
people get stopping traffic
uh i consider i mean that's fault that
should be false imprisonment it's a it
should be treated as a very serious
crime
i really disagree with you you know i
think no like i think protests are
stopping traffic it's like straight to
jail
everybody and throw the book at those
people because that's it's it's
incredibly selfish there are people
who are trying to just get to work go to
their jobs it's incredibly scary
right you're just like you're you're at
the mercy of this mob um
and it's just it's the most selfish way
to protest possible
it's completely indifferent to like the
amount of time and energy you're taking
away from everybody who's blocked
you're just you're deciding you're more
important than they are that becomes a
felony right
blocking traffic i think so i think it's
like a third degree felony i think
they've been much more aggressive about
it and i
i really disagree with that when i think
that you know
if it was just a bunch of say like i
don't know code pink
and they're holding hands in the middle
of dc singing songs and the cops have to
walk up and one by one arrest them and
remove them and it takes
20 or 30 minutes non-violence of
disobedience is a good thing we don't
want people to be getting violent
um i mean i'm okay with that except do
it on a sidewalk like get out of the
road
but that's the point the point is to
create some kind of circumstance where
it generates attention
and my point is that i think that's not
something we should incentivize and
instead that we should deter
i think a fair point is that see people
standing on the road create a very
serious risk standing in a road and you
probably shouldn't stand in a road
period
right my thing is more just like we want
we need to make sure there's a space
maintained where people can be
to a certain degree disruptive
peacefully and non-violently
and it's already illegal so typically
what happens is when people are holding
hands in the street they immediately get
arrested
sometimes takes longer if they use like
chains to like link their hands together
or those like metal tubes
but they when a peaceful protester
stands in the street the cop walks up
coughs them and walks them away they
clear the traffic relatively quickly
and the protesters get their point
across they do get charged it's usually
a misdemeanor slap on the wrist
and then they're not going around
smashing windows and beating people in
the streets like they're doing now
i mean i think like well there's already
laws that are you know don't
we aren't seriously punishing people on
the road and they still
you know i don't think that's a way to
divert them from breaking windows
i think it's like you know felony is
kind of intense though for that man
right but well then there's don't do it
like just don't do it it's the law
don't do it you know i mean i think you
have to think about the worst case
scenario right like what if an ambulance
is trying to get through
this traffic and they can't or like
there was a video that went viral
um a while ago of some guy he got out of
his car
and a mob was blocking him from getting
in the road and this is a doctor
and he was like he like worked in the er
or something he's like i need to get to
work
patience the challenge i suppose is the
difference between an unruly mob in the
street
and like a bunch of hippies holding
hands singing and then the cops come and
clear them out
yeah i think those are different things
but in this scenario it was
a giant mob of people in an intersection
right that's right
and what's stopping the hippies from
getting a permit like if you want to if
you want to march on the street
get a permit there's ways to do that i
don't know man first amendment says
piece of peaceably assembled well do you
guys remember the la riots more recently
not the actual l.a riots
in the 60s but there were la rios yeah
the 90s
60s yeah i'm a little bit off like 30
years
they blocked a highway in la and there
was an ambulance that was stuck in the
traffic and a little girl
died because of it like that's for me
the biggest argument against
like blocking traffic and i kind of
agree with that then they should be
charged with murder yeah absolutely
right like that's a serious issue well i
think we should just you know at the
outset just deter this behavior entirely
like i mean if if people actually start
going to jail for serious time for doing
this it will stop
people will find other ways to make
their point heard and there's plenty of
ways in this world to get your point
across
yeah my main thing is like if it's
already illegal why are we making more
laws for it
because people are still doing it so the
punishments aren't severe enough
apparently
i'm not sure that they care i mean i
will say a point i've made in the past
few days is that the cost
for riding is too low and these people
know this
even though it is a felony to go and do
you know burn a building to the ground
they know they're gonna get cut loose
that let you see that lady in in
uh portland who burned down the or was
that fire to the police union building
they released her without bail yeah they
released her yeah it's just uh rioting
is not drug addiction where people can't
stop right right like and that it's not
and therefore it's like overly punitive
into chronic no
you don't have to riot you have no
addiction to writing you're just doing
it because you want to
so stop it we just need to change the
law so that people go right to jail
this uh this woman apparently she got
informed on because
some one of these antifa guys in
portland is apparently a snitch she was
arrested apparently last year i guess
and she was released and all the charges
were dropped
if this woman was if the charges were
not dropped
and she got a year in jail or a year
plus in prison
she would not have been there to set
fire to this police association building
they cut her loose dropped the charges
and they knew she was a violent
terroristic extremist then she goes and
does it again
and what happens she gets f i think it's
five felony charges
wow and they release her with without
without bail on our own recognizance i
think that's called right
right and i mean the beauty of doing
this in you know conservative states
there's a lot of blue cities and there's
still blue cities in in florida
but all of a sudden they've got you know
the state attorney general can come in
and tell them to knock it off right
right now you're essentially oregon is
totally dependent
on federal law enforcement um and the
fbi run by
a republican pr administration at some
point in the future
otherwise you're just you're just sol
yeah
i like the uh you can't get released
until your first court hearing
you're caught in a riot you know there
are challenges about this
uh typically my thing is blackstone's
formulation the presumption of innocence
it's really difficult to you you might
be walking through the wrong place at
the right wrong time
and they'll charge you with being in a
riot and you know what then
right well i mean i think the the right
answer is to really reduce the number of
riots
like that let's let's start there if we
just reduce the number of riots then
that also reduces the number of people
who are randomly walking through makes
police's job a lot easier
means they can focus on combating crime
in their cities
and not have to send these huge forces
of people just to you know
deal with unruly rioters so so you know
when i asked about
why make new laws if it's already
illegal you said something to the effect
of the punishment must not have been
severe enough
right like if it's still happening
despite being illegal all the time
we are not deterring it sufficiently
because the district attorneys aren't
prosecuting it
that might be true but this is a
solution to that as well right if you
create
new state laws with severe punishments
and
you know essentially you create an
environment also where the state
attorney general is going to want to
enforce those laws if local district
attorneys are not
and that authority i'm pretty sure is
always there so long as at the state
level
i guess my bigger concern then is one of
the statements made by democrats is that
this is going to be disproportionately
used
it's going to be biased it's going to be
used against them
they're they're half right i think if
you look at the evidence
they've consistently the the black lives
matter the antivirus have consistently
gotten away with
serious violent extremism i mean how
many people died in the riots
or peripheral to the riots of last year
it was like 30 something something
yeah there were there were 19 i think
deaths directly related and then
peripheral deaths like people and
ambulances that couldn't
get to the hospital and stuff like that
these people
have gotten away with i mean kamala
harris solicited donations to get these
people out of jail joe biden and staff
donated to these funds to get these
people out of jail
and then people voted for them then you
look at the the people at the capitol
there's one lady apparently the door was
open and she had no idea what was going
on until she walked in
you know dumbfounded and bewildered like
everybody else and now she's in solitary
confinement facing like 40 years in
prison
yeah i mean that's the cur that's the
status quo the left
gets off a lot easier and that's not all
about like selective prosecution that's
also about
you know 50 to 60 years of leftist
organizing infrastructure and protest
infrastructure still existing
i mean oh yeah the national lawyers
guild they're still around and in the
70s
they were hiding terrorists right
weather underground terrorists and we
i mean it's amazing when you actually
read about what the 70s weather
underground did they were bombing all
over the place
um and uh they they just got
six months they got like probation when
they finally they were they were
fugitives for ten years and they finally
turned themselves in and got probation
who was weather underground i've heard
of them a lot bill ayers
bill ayers so uh weather underground
came out of students for democrats
students for a democratic society a
radical left-wing student group um
after in the i think in the very early
70s
um they made the decision to that you
know we actually are we need the
revolution is coming
and so uh after like they went to a big
protest in chicago and a bunch of them
got indicted on
various like rioting assault charges a
bunch of them instead of returning to
face those charges they went
underground um which at the time just
meant well
okay i'm not going to show for my court
date i'm not going to be a fugitive and
i'm going to go get
you know new identity documents and and
just live under the radar
and not be you know not be employed it
was much easier to do then because
it was just easy to fake make get a fake
id no internet
right so um that was you know and so
there was a big there's a group it ended
up being about 150 left-wing people and
they started out they i mean apparently
there was a plan to actually go after
and
set off bombs in an army base while
people were there that failed and
ultimately a bunch of them killed
themselves in a bomb accident in their
own town house
uh and then after that they decided
we're only gonna bomb things
symbolically but they were
you know there was just there was a
bombing campaign all over the place
where they would just set off bombs and
you know energy stations and random
places to make a political point
so we have decades of that
infrastructure and the remnants of that
still exist today
yeah so when it comes to this new law
how long until a democrat wins florida
assuming they do
maybe maybe it swings back hardly the
direction in the next few years maybe
not maybe i mean
it was fairly close this time around
democrat takes over and then all of a
sudden the republicans find themselves
with with
you know a boot on their face well i
mean it's possible but you know
i think republicans republicans
generally don't riot and you know one of
the things they said about january 6 is
the reason they
were even able to get into the capital
is because republicans generally don't
do that
you know they weren't prepared they
weren't the capital police weren't
prepared for it at all they were really
understaffed what if a right-wing group
decides to march around and they got
flags and they find themselves marching
in the street
and also they're all committing felonies
and they'll get locked up i mean
don't do that the law says don't do it
but if if you're
if you're a regular person and you're
coming out waving your flag you're on a
street corner and everyone's cheering
and then you start marching and then
you're in the street not realizing
what's going on you don't know the law
and then all of a sudden they're like
thank you so much for this law
that that 40 you know that that's 50
year old grandmother is now a felon
and they lock her up and they put her in
solitary i mean they've
one they've already done that in federal
law um right right that's what i'm
saying so it's like
i expect more it's quite possible that
democrats will use this stuff against us
but
i mean i think the net trade-off given
how few sort of
riots there are from the right like
january 6 was such a bizarre aberration
i mean
i remember just being surprised it's
like our side never does this this is
left uh did this
all summer and all all the time the
right never does i literally published a
video at 1 pm that day where i was like
nothing's happening
trump's speaking everyone's waving
little flags this is boring
yeah and then 10 minutes later they
pushed past the barricade and then 40
minutes later
you know oh so stupid yeah so stupid so
anyway i mean i'm just i'm not
pro-riding like i just don't care don't
riot i'm concerned how they redefine
riot
in the coming years because if they make
a law about what you can and can't do
when you're writing then all of a sudden
they're going to make a law about what
the word right yeah
that's in it it changes it to three or
more people engaging in tumultuous
activity so if i go on the corner and
start playing music and i have four
people around me yelling
and they're excited they could say i'm
rioting maybe but then there's there's
always this first amendment constraint
in the background right yeah
so like i mean i think and and i'm
confident in the ability of federal
courts
to enforce the first amendment and
strike down laws
even just as applied right if they try
to use one of these riot laws to
something that is clearly first
amendment protected activity is
i'm confident a court strike it down
what are they going to do about
journalists who are there covering it
one
one there's the problem of people there
who are actual journalists who have
you know their cameras and stuff and
then
there's people who fake it you know
there have been a lot of people at these
riots who have fake press credentials
so are they going to arrest everybody
including
people who are there as reporters or are
they going to let reporters go
and then have people fake it they'll
arrest them
they you know two of our two of our
reporters got arrested
yeah yeah uh i remember i'll tell you
this the the simple thing is
if you're a journalist and you're
working the protest beat be nice to the
cops
like be calm very calm and have your
press credentials readily available
ask for a supervisor very calmly and
politely if it doesn't happen keep your
mouth shut
so i've been in so many of these
circumstances and i remember in dc on uh
trump's inauguration several journalists
got pulled out of the mass arrest
i was one of them why had my card i
asked for a supervisor
the guy came over and said you're under
arrest i was i just want to let you know
i'm pressed and he goes no doesn't
matter i was like
you got it just letting you know he came
back later and he looked at some
journalists and he was like you come
with me you come with me and i was like
yo yo no
come with me he pulled us out show me
your card he said all right you guys are
good to go
you know sorry about that some other
journalists were in the crowd screaming
at the top of their lungs you
[ __ ] you can't rest on my
journal
they went to jail and then they had all
of the activists cheer them on they came
out
and these people are hardcore activists
that's why they're screaming at cops and
they're angry
so as part of the job you're not
supposed to get arrested but you get
arrested
a real a real professional journalist in
my opinion gets arrested and they
grumble about it
and they keep their mouth shut and they
let their boss know the moment it's
happening if they can
they say you know they'll yell to
someone tell you know channel five i'm
being arrested and then they'll
peacefully put their hands behind the
back and then go through the motions and
then when the
you know the station will call them the
police usually say okay you're free to
go
but when you scream in their faces and
start a fight and you get locked up
if you're screaming at the cops and
starting a fight with them you're
probably not a real
journalist or a real reporter yep i
think it's fair to say
we defend the act of journalism someone
becomes a journalist the moment they're
engaging in journalism
but if you combine at any point the act
of journalism with the act of rioting or
can or or screaming at cops
now you're an active participant you may
be in active journalism
but you're also open this way the first
amendment says peaceably assemble
meaning if you violently assemble or
illegally assemble then
you're not peaceably assembling illegal
is where it gets interesting and
there are probably case law challenges
but the general idea is
if you're not breaking the law or
putting people at risk
you're probably fine the same thing is
true for if you're engaging in an act of
the press
if you start acting violently you know
the press is implied that you're being
peaceful
if you're now throwing bricks at people
and filming it that's not journalism you
know
i think it's fair to say it's just being
yourself throw bricks is not journalism
this is in florida is this where this is
yeah yeah but there's there's like i
think 13 states that have the same bill
so if it went through then would a
journalist who steps onto the street
be committing a felony doubtful well
they could charge it but i don't think
it would fly they could charge it
because they'll say
you know let's say you're there and
you're filming and you're in a group of
three or more engaging in tumultuous
activity
they'll say ah you're in the street
felony you're under arrest then you'll
go
you'll probably have to go before a
judge you'll tell the judge i'm a
reporter here's where i work the judge
will be like okay you're free to go
if you can't prove you work somewhere
he'll probably say i don't believe you
you know your court date is this it's
tough
it's not easy the first amendment is
interesting it defends the press but now
everybody's the press
so i guess the the the the problem now
is like
the question you ask if you're a
journalist and you enter the street and
you're obstructing it now
got a problem i mean i don't know like
i'm looking at the statute it changes
the definition to someone who
participates in a violent public
disturbance involving an assembly of
three or more persons
acting with a common intent to assist
each other in a violent and disorderly
context so yeah
violence is part of writing that
wouldn't include journalists right now
journalists are free then
unless you're filming yourself throwing
bricks at people right internally
if you're filming and throwing a water
bottle then the more important part is
you're throwing a water bottle
exactly thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you